[موسيقى]
بعيدًا ، أخذتني السفينة
بعيدًا بعيدًا عن
ذكريات الأشخاص الذين يهتمون بما إذا كانت
[موسيقى]
لا أعرف ما إذا كان الأمر يستحق ذلك بعد الآن
[موسيقى] بين
ذراعي أردت فقط
[موسيقى]
i
لن يسمح لك بالرحيل أبدًا
إذا وعدت ألا
تتلاشى
أبدًا
[موسيقى]
آمالنا وتوقعاتنا
آمال وتوقعات
[موسيقى
] أردت فقط
[موسيقى]
عندما أنظر
إلى عينيك
[موسيقى]
متوهجة لأنك
الشخص الذي يجعل نشاطه يرتفع ،
أنت الشخص الذي في
داخلي ، أعطني سبب وجودي
إلى جانبك فقط من أجلك
[موسيقى]
معك وأريد أن أكون
معك وأريد البقاء
معك
إلى الأبد حتى النهاية
[موسيقى]
[  موسيقى]
ألكساندر
[موسيقى
] تنادي الرجل
سيدي ، هل يمكنك مساعدتي
[موسيقى]
يطلق عليه لا أعرف مكان
النوم هناك في مكان ما يمكنك إخباري به
صافرة [موسيقى] أثناء عبوره الشارع
[  الموسيقى]
إنه يوم آخر بالنسبة لي ولكم في
الجنة وكل
ما عليك فعله هو التفكير في الأمر
يا رب
ألا يوجد أي شيء آخر  يمكنك أن تفعل
[موسيقى]
يجب أن يكون هناك شيء
يمكنك قوله من السطور الموجودة على وجهها
يمكنه أن يرى أنها كانت هناك
ربما تم نقلها من كل مكان
لأنها لم تضربه
أو
[الموسيقى]
إنه يوم آخر  من أجلك
أنت و
[الموسيقى]
تكون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لك
[الموسيقى]
م